there is one place in america where the
mourning for the duke of edinburgh
is especially personal we don't yet know
whether the duke and duchess of sussex
will leave their home in montecito in
california to attend the funeral in
windsor so far the only public statement
has been on their website
thank you for your service it read
you'll be greatly missed
that is a sentiment shared at the very
top in the united states
jill and i and the entire administration
send our condolences to her majesty
queen elizabeth ii
on the loss of uh prince philip uh
he was a heck of a guy he uh you know it
was
his lifetime of service the united
kingdom and the whole commonwealth was
visible to everybody for a long long
time
his predecessors too paid their tributes
donald trump wrote that prince philip
defined british dignity and grace
he personified the quiet reserve stern
fortitude
and unbending integrity of the united
kingdom
he wrote that he and the first lady saw
firsthand how the monarchy epitomizes
and carries on the virtues of the
british people
and no one did so more than prince
philip barack obama wrote
through his extraordinary example his
royal highness prince philip proved that
true partnership
has room for both ambition and
selflessness
all in service of something greater our
thoughts are with her majesty the queen
the royal family and the british people
this is the place the duke and duchess
of sussex chose as their refuge from the
glare of royal life but
their presence here has served to
increase interest amongst americans
in him his american family and stories
like the death of his grandfather
well you know we saw him it was you can
see it's december 27th
stacy writes very proud of the photo she
snapped of the duke walking his dog on
the beach here
and is hopeful of a royal healing in a
time of grief
very sad and my first reaction was that
it was
sad that there seems to be a family rift
because i don't think that um
that they would like this isn't perfect
timing for his death i mean there's
never a perfect time
but he made it to 99 and he was um very
influential in my opinion
i think the differences have been
somewhat sensationalized
i don't think that they're actually as
uh significant as maybe
people want to make them the attractions
of their new life here are pretty clear
to see
but as in any family at a time of
sadness the pool towards home
is a powerful force greg milam sky news
montecito in california